battlefield 2042 dropped a bombshell on
us by revealing an awesome new game mode
letting players relive some of the
golden years
of battlefield's history the new mode is
officially called battlefield portal and
lets players create their own scenarios
and join custom servers that incorporate
guns maps and factions from different
battlefield games
in this video we're going to break down
everything you need to know about
battlefield 2042's new mode
if you want to stay in the know
including when the 2042 beta will happen
and what it looks like make sure to pop
a quick like and subscribe
because man i am telling you the news is
coming in hot
so let's dive in battlefield portal is a
first in the series
allowing players to enjoy maps from
battlefield games of the past with the
newest frostbite engine and added
touches
crafted by studio ripple effect formerly
known as dice la
the game specifically brought back to
life in portal are
battlefield 1942 battlefield bad company
2
and battlefield 3. so if you were hoping
to see some titans from 2142 or any of
the vietnam backdrops you are out of
luck for now at least
that being said all three of those games
have fan favorite locations included in
portal like
caspian border el alamine and eureka
harbor
portal allows you to remix elements from
all four battlefield games including
their characters
maps guns and vehicles into custom
experiences
but you can also change the rules of the
game allowing you to create game modes
that are completely new
battlefield portal will have custom
modes that players can dive into
as curated by the devs themselves
however
community created experiences seem to be
the biggest point of emphasis
think halo forge players can customize
different aspects of their game
regardless of whichever era those
elements are from
at a high level you can select tons of
variables including what guns
vehicles factions and maps are in your
custom match
and then you can get extremely granular
with attachments damage health and a lot
of other small tweaks
that's right if you want to pit the
germans from world war
ii against a bunch of expats from 2042
you
absolutely can the only thing you can't
do at this stage
is mix different factions on a single
team battlefield portal will have six
classic maps combined with the seven
all-out warfare maps meaning a total of
13 available to players at launch
which is nice to hear honestly give me
all the maps
it's important to note that not every
location from those past games will be
included in battlefield portal
only two from each game are there at
launch battlefield 1942 will bring back
el alamine one of the largest
battlefield maps of all time
and battle of the bulge bad company 2
will bring back eureka harbor and
valparaiso
and lastly battlefield 3 will bring
caspian border
and no shark canals the maps have been
updated running the latest version of
frostbite in battlefield 2042's engine
which means adding awesome elements like
extensive destruction to places that
never had it before such as 1942's
battle of the bulge on the other hand
you have maps like valparaiso from bad
company 2
that'll have different low tide versions
with expanded play area
and this is to help accommodate the
significantly larger
128 player lobbies being able to see
some of these iconic maps come to life
on next gen is extremely exciting and i
can't wait to see all three of those
games getting the current frostbite
engine makeover
the weapons vehicles and equipment will
be making a return
and all of their retouched next-gen
glory as well
vehicles returning are chosen by dice
but fans will be pleased to see
a much wider selection of their favorite
weapons or exotic ones like the xm8
worth mentioning too that the weapons
included are based on player data
and usage when you combine all of the
arsenal from these three remastered
games as well
as the content from the world of 2042
you have
over 40 vehicles 40 weapons and 30
gadgets
that is a lot of tools to unleash chaos
with on the battlefield
all of the maps will be playable in 4k
at 60 frames per second
and next gen platforms can enjoy the
added 128 player lobbies
ps4 and xbox one owners will still get
to enjoy the reimagined maps but with 64
player matches how will these matches be
balanced you may ask
they won't be developers stated that it
is up to the players to figure that out
and there are a lot of ways to do it
you can change a lot of core settings
like allowing early reloads adjusting
the damage multiplier
putting on friendly fire or even
changing the speed of projectiles
battlefield portal is wide open for the
most part in regards to the game's rules
except no special terrain editing so
what you can do
is change the parameters of any
battlefield match but you can't change
the integrity of the game for it to be
anything
that isn't a general battlefield match
so no
you cannot make your own custom battle
royale if that is what you were hoping
to do
if there's one thing that i have faith
in however it is the imagination of this
community
and coming up with experiences that will
be truly memorable
also kind of a big deal but there's a
logic editor
you'll be able to customize a game mode
and experience from scratch and if
you've got some script building skills
in your arsenal
there's very little limitations on what
you can create short of breaking the
game
one of the examples we saw at the
preview event was setting a script rule
in the logic editor where every time a
player got a kill
that same player was healed to full
health or
if you got a kill you can force weapons
to swap for everyone on the team
most of the logic editor stuff is way
too advanced for me
but i know some of y'all watching this
video are already cracking your knuckles
eager to get going and creating a truly
custom experience
here's something else super cool
battlefield portal will allow you to
level up
and gain xp as if you were playing a
regular all-out warfare game mode
usually when it comes to things like
custom servers or private matches
it's hard to gain xp if at all since
players can essentially
game the system there are safety nets of
sorts in battlefield portal that will
prevent players from abusing this model
to gain xp
but ripple effect says that progression
will work in portal
just as in other gameplay modes in short
the xp system in battlefield portal will
be more or less the same as that in
battlefield 2042
with the caveat that portal has certain
safeguards to protect itself
from players trying to take advantage
and speed up their xp gains
we got a look at the pre-alpha creation
menus and it seems
really intuitive most of the featured
experiences are really straightforward
like making a bad company 2 versus a
1942 type mode
but if you want to get really creative
you just go through a series of menus
clicking which options you want and that
snipers vs shotguns mode you wanted is
suddenly a reality
you can set up the game mode style that
you want be it conquest
conquest small rush or something
completely custom
you can choose the maps and the map
rotation from any number of classic or
2042 maps and you can mix and match
and you can even mess with things like
team distribution putting 100 players on
one team and only 28 on the other
to be completely honest with you
battlefield portal sounds like the game
mode i didn't know i needed
mainly because i didn't quite think it
was possible clearly
the developers have taken into account
just how passionate all of you are
about some of these older battlefield
games and they have taken the huge task
of recreating
all of those experiences from
battlefield's golden era so let me know
how you feel about battlefield portal
and which maps you're going to jump into
first
or if you're more excited to craft your
own distinct custom experience
also let me know if there are other maps
you hope to see in battlefield portal's
future
because ripple effect didn't quite
reveal much about what could be added in
the future
but they've mentioned that battlefield
portal is just the first step in the
beginning
of a larger journey they're always
looking to interact with the community
to find out what you guys might want to
see happen to portal over time
if you're excited and eager and just
can't wait to get your hands on
battlefield 2042
you'll get a chance to play the
battlefield beta this september
until then we'll see you next time
you